هذا هو المكان الذي تختفي فيه الغالبية العظمى
من التلوث مع كل
ضربة مدمرة ، هناك رد فعل قاتل 10 -
ضرب عنصر من الدبابير هذا
المبنى ، حيث تم طرد أي ذخيرة لم
تنفجر في ذلك الانفجار الأولي
، تم إلقاؤها من
هنا ويمكنها  السفر لمسافة تصل إلى عدة مئات من
الأمتار ، يمكن للذخيرة مثل هذه الذخيرة الحية
أن تقتل المدنيين في كثير من الأحيان
بعد فترة طويلة من توقف القتال ، لذا سترى من
قبل نوع المذبحة
التي خلفتها
شاحنات الذخيرة التي سبق وصفها
بالتفجير في مارس / آذار القوات الأوكرانية
في مستودع المزرعة هذا الذي يضم أطنانًا
من القذائف والصواريخ الروسية ، لا يمكنني إلا
تخيل كرة النار والصوت الذي
تم إنتاجه عندما حدث
لفريق التخلص من الذخائر المتفجرة
في تشيناي ، فنحن لا نذهب في حالة
عدوانية ، ومن الواضح أن
هناك تهديدًا يتمثل في  حقيقي جدا
سنستمر مع أه
بالبحث مباشرة إذا قلت توقف في
أي وقت توقف الإعلان فورا  فانس
علينا العودة إلى هنا من أجل
سلامتنا الخاصة ، فهذا يوضح مدى خطورة
هذا العمل وقد استغرقت هذه
المنطقة الصغيرة عدة أيام
ولم تنته حتى الآن ،
لقد خدشنا السطح فقط وأنت
حصلت على دولة بأكملها من المحتمل ، نعم ،
كيف يمكنك القيام بهذه المهمة إذا كنت
أقوم بهذا العمل ووجودي هنا في أوكرانيا
أزيل ذرة واحدة مهما كانت صغيرة أو
مهما كانت كبيرة ، فهذا ينقذ حياة واحدة
بالنسبة لي شخصيًا ، هذا هو الهدف
الذي وصلت إليه ،
حسنًا
توقف  عندما يشتبه في هذه البقعة ، يجب على
الجميع العودة إلى
قائد الفريق جون ألدريدج يجب أن يذهب
وحيدًا
باستخدام أطراف أصابعه فقط ،
يعمل جون بحذر شديد ، وقد
تم تصميم هذه الخلايا لتدمير
المواقع الدفاعية إذا كان مسلحًا ، حتى ولو
أقل دفعة يمكن أن تفجرها.
هناك خربشة من
خلال عدم معرفة ما الذي ستعثر عليه بالضبط ،
نعم إنه أمر مثير للاهتمام أعتقد
أنه شيء تعتاد عليه
بعد الوقت ولكن لا يزال هناك هذا
العنصر
منكم يعرف نوعًا من الأدرينالين
يركل قليلاً نعم ، ويمكن تحريك بعض
حبات العرق
هذه بأمان
قريبًا سيكون لديهم قادة الفريق الأوكراني
لتطهير أرضهم ،
وستكون هذه مهمة هائلة ، كما تقول
ناتاليا منذ كل هذا  يجب أن يتم ذلك
بعناية ، لا يمكنك التسرع في هذه المهمة بشكل
جيد بدلاً من نعم حتى لو توقفت هذه الحرب
اليوم ، فقد يستغرق الأمر سنوات
حتى يكون البلد آمنًا
David McKenzie CNN genif Ukraine